pas d'accident fort heureusement lors du
meeting aérien des ailes de légende qui
a réuni plus de 20000 personnes près de
toulouse
ce meeting a été l'occasion de revoir
évoluer des avions qui ont connu leur
heure de gloire lors de la seconde
guerre mondiale ambiance avec christophe
la rocca et olivier combe pour attirer
les parents il suffit souvent de savoir
intéresser les enfants être pilote d'un
fouga magister à 6 ans ça n'est pas
donné à tout le monde
en revanche le métier d'instructeur est
souvent un peu ingrat quant à l'avion
vole droit qui va descendre tu as volé
horizontalement et il va vendre et des
fois ils sont fascinés par l intéressé
aux footeux du reste de l'avion a dit
que la celui d'avril et un trio mort
quels sont ces rations
mais le clou de ce salon des avions de
légende c'était tout de même eu ces
zones de guerre qui ont connu leur heure
de gloire il y à 50 ans ce curtis p 40
par exemple est peu connu en europe où
il demeure le seul exemplaire en état de
vol
il s'est pourtant illustré pendant des
années au dessus du pacifique
aujourd'hui grâce à la patience d'un
collectionneur il a retrouvé toute sa
dextérité en vol
les dents de requin sur le nez de
l'avion symboliser l'agressivité des
pilotes américains
une coutume toujours en vigueur dans l'
us air force cette fantastique par la
puissance les vibrations bon la fêtée
par sa chaleur chez à plus de 650 à
l'heure c'est à quelque chose quand même
extraordinaire pas tous les jours on se
promène 650 à valenciennes pour ce que
ces exhibitions ray laissé de marbre le
salon des avions de légende avait
réservé une surprise
un baptême de l'air en dc3 le fameux
dakota l'avion de ligne de la fin des
années 30
visage inquiet pour les uns émotion pour
les autres trente minutes de souvenirs
inoubliables
c'était génial extra
d'ailleurs toutes les compagnies
aériennes devraient dès rumeurs des
avions comme ça a vraiment c'est super
phénoménal
je crois que je garderai avant sur une
liste on va plus beaucoup cette campagne
au siège quand même
et voilà comment les avions vous rêvez
de 7 à 77 ans